[Music]
now one of the answers it seems to me is
a guaranteed annual income a guaranteed
minimum income for all people and for
all families of our country boom what's
up everyone welcome to simulation I'm
your host solid sake on super excited to
be talking about basic income all of the
trials happening around the world
sharing the stories of what's happening
and how to best maximize our potential
we have Owen Poindexter joining us on
the show hello
Hey good to be here thanks for coming on
I really appreciate it
very grateful that we met when you were
introducing Andrew yang mm-hm
and when he was speaking in San
Francisco and I'm really grateful he
wanted to come on the show Owens
backgrounds awesome he's done a hundred
and three plus episodes of the basic
income podcast over the last three years
and he's been featuring representatives
he's been featuring cofounders of
companies union leaders from around the
world people that are actually running
all these trials across Europe across
Africa across Asia across Latin America
Creed and even in the United States so
we're gonna be unpacking all of those he
also ran for California State Assembly
and he has just as just fascinated with
sharing these stories and all the links
are below to the basic income podcast as
well as Owens website and his Twitter so
go and check those out Owen let's start
off with this big history perspective on
civilization we find ourselves as
stewards of earth what is your current
take on the state of humanity the state
of humanity well I feel like we're in
this place right now where we can
envision a society in realistic real
terms where people by and large are
taken care of you have access to health
care you have access to education you
have a basic income perhaps to cover
your basic needs we don't have that now
obviously but we could imagine that
happening in the near age term in the US
we could imagine that happening
in a lot of countries around the world
eventually we can have that conversation
globally and we can also you know I have
to feel necessary to throw in that we
can imagine tackling climate change
we're not there we're you know a ways
away and some of these things are not
going in that direction but there is a
lot of very exciting momentum toward
creating a society that is actually the
one we're like when you're a kid
thinking about what the world should be
like that starts to look like that you
know it's taken a long time and not
everything isn't going in a positive
direction but we have the tools now to
get to a place like that and so it's
it's a little terrifying but very
exciting yeah one of the huge things
that you bring up is this imagination
and you actually had an episode where
you were talking about reset and we
loved thinking about this reset what how
would you
update civilization in order to have not
had some of the errors that we've had in
the past like what would if it looked
like to have had a basic income
throughout to make sure that no people
were left behind that humans were all
being able to be maximally flourished
and so when you take this like imagining
of a child where they have when they're
born and they have healthcare they have
the basic needs that they need it on the
mass house hierarchy met like what would
that do to every single human on the
planet and that's a very beautiful
vision that I think that you know we are
like you said taking incremental steps
to get to now you know this is the
importance of this like imagination that
you indicate do you do you feel as
though the people that you talk to
around the world they're slowly moving
the ball forward and getting towards
that imagination yeah I think so so yeah
I mean anyone who's in the basic income
space some part of their brain is in
that realm of thinking of a better
society you know some are very detailed
very policy focused very like it you
know it should be this much it should
come from these sources not from this it
shouldn't you know and so on and so
forth and some are just saying that
people should be able to kind of do what
they want with their lives like maybe
there should be some obligation or or
incentive to contribute to the larger
whole but in a world where we have the
resources we have the ability to
distribute those resources you know
where people are have a baseline where
they're taken care of you know we can't
ensure that you're in a good mood all
the time but we can ensure that you have
food you have housing you have access to
health care and money is this magical
thing that is so efficient I can send
you money as easily as I can send you an
email these days and so and we've seen
and what I'm sure will get into this
that when you give people money they
don't they don't just spend it on you
know drugs and alcohol people have this
idea that you know well if you took
people free money they're just gonna
drink it away they're gonna spend it on
video games and you know some people
will and maybe that's okay maybe it's
okay that some people they just want to
smoke pot and play video games and
there's seven billion of us I think it's
okay if a few people are just doing that
I think enough people have this this
social Civic mindset that they want to
contribute they want to be part of a
society and you don't need to threaten
people with poverty to do that mm-hmm
yeah one of the things that yeah Ron and
I talked about is that one of the
reasons why we see poor people is
because it's to scare the middle class
yeah yeah yeah and this is this is a
very serious thing you don't need to be
threatened with poverty when your birth
into this beautiful abundant world and
like how we get there is one of the
major questions you start listing these
you know really strong mental health
benefits we have tons of people that are
very excited about about being able to
contribute on a civic engagement level
and even though small percentage of
people will do things that are maybe
just you know hang out and stuff
whatever that's cool because we have so
many people that actually care and want
to make it better and then yeah now the
all the practical questions you know how
do you figure out how to read this how
do you how do you take money there's all
these dividends that we're gonna be
talking about we're gonna be unpacking
all these potential funds all these
scenarios of basic incomes that are
happening around the world cuz there's
so many different ways to tackle it and
it's cool because you can actually see
different like permutations of how to
tackle it happening in countries and
then the best ones will kind of win the
best code of how to
tackle it will win so you started doing
you know you're born in Brooklyn and
then you moved with your wife for she
was doing law school at Berkeley yep she
has moved to the Bay Area and then when
you're in the Bay Area you get involved
in these you know these these meetups
yeah and you're learning more about
basic income you meet Jim your co-host
of the yeah the podcast yeah yeah and so
tell us about like if I need you
involved in California assembly so how
did this activism and basic income life
start up for you yeah well I should
definitely credit Jim view my co-host on
the podcast and Sandy and aaanthor Amin
who essentially built the basic income
community in the Bay Area and they were
able to do that because there are people
like me who had heard of the idea we're
interested in the idea you know some
from the automation perspective some
through fighting poverty just a lot of
different angles that people come at
basic income from but they just said you
know if you're into basic income come to
this time at this place and we'll talk
about it and so it was a very organic
development and they occasionally host
what are called creative fons and so
that I think was one of the big
galvanizing moments for the Bay Area
basic income world was they hosted to
create a thon where people could just
come up with different projects
somewhere art project somewhere policy
projects I kind of designed on paper
ideas around creating a basic income in
San Francisco and and through these
meetups you know one day I said you know
I've been thinking about starting a
basic income podcast and Jim said I have
been thinking about that too and you
know not much later we started this show
and because we are the basic income
podcast others have started up I don't
know if any of our still going right now
but we've been able to bring in a lot of
the big names in the basic income space
because it still is you know it's
getting bigger and bigger all the time
but it's still a small enough world that
you can be if you're in Nebraska and you
want to start the basic income community
there you can be that person you can be
so-and-so of Nebraska who is the hub of
basic income there whereas if you know
if you're fighting for universal health
care you should have
we do that but you won't be the only one
which is great but but yeah so I got
involved in this community it started to
grow and grow the podcast kind of became
this hub of of my own activism and my
own learning about the the policy and
meaning more and more people involved in
that world and what I started to notice
is that there's a lot of excitement
around the world you use talk about
basic income and a lot of people are
into the idea they've heard of it in the
Bay Area at least a lot of people have
heard of it and support it and then you
get up to politicians the people who
could actually make it happen if our
politicians wanted a basic income
tomorrow they could but they don't want
to touch it there's so many other things
they could be talking about issues that
people are familiar with I don't know
how they feel and it's not controversial
you don't get all these questions about
how you pay for it and what is it and
what our people are gonna spend it on
and so politicians don't want to explain
things they don't want one of them a
basic income supporter told me that
who's an elected official said if you're
explaining you're losing and so and it's
a new concept for a lot of people even
here in San Francisco and so that needs
to change if you're explaining you're
winning because right yeah the math show
the science exactly the trajectory yeah
your potential yeah and running for
office really exposed me to a lot of
that political realm but so I decided to
run for office to be someone who's not
afraid to explain who's not afraid to
you know carry the torch for this
concept that's that's big and new and
unfamiliar even in you know I'm in the
East Bay a very kind of liberal hub of
the US but a lot of people hadn't heard
of it or were wary of it for a lot of
the reasons that people are wary of
basic income and yeah just on the
explaining or losing thing I got to go
to the California Democratic convention
in San Diego in in 2018 and you see
these very practice politicians like to
have a new some and turning of iego Rosa
you know all these people who they are
good at politics and they just have a
cadence in their voice that means you
are going to applaud you can say things
like like everyone deserves an education
they they just do and when they when
they hit do everyone claps and it's like
it's like the applause sign lit up and
they're not explaining what education is
they're not explaining why that's a good
policy they're not explaining anything
really they're just hitting a principal
and you're like I agree with that
principle and they set it in a way that
hits me and on a bodily sense and you
clap and you like that person and that's
what being good at politics is and you
know for better or worse that's that's
our system a system that's held up
reasonably well I would say you know
over the centuries for all its flaws and
you know I certainly happy to get into
those flaws but but it's one where it's
difficult to come in with a new idea
it's difficult to be that person who is
putting their their political energy
their political stakes on this idea that
people haven't necessarily heard of and
they're not sure what they think about
it so I decided I would do a little bit
of bushwhacking there yeah this was also
you know so interesting that when you
came you were explaining that you had
just you know interviewed someone in Sri
Lanka - that was taking on this yeah
being the universe the basic income
person in Sri Lanka and like you said
it's still such a nascent movement where
you could be the person in Nebraska or
whatever country in the world or state
in the world and and step up and be that
that that that leader in that area now
you also started teaching us about how a
lot of the political sphere as you
started entering it was a little bit
just following some sort of a cadence
and kind of like a code of politics that
doesn't necessarily explain what you
said how are we going to make sure that
every child gets an education what
education is a child going to be getting
how can that child be fully actualized
right these the further levels of the
principle of the top principle and so
that's very important that that you
bring that up because now I hope you
know more Millennials and Gen Z that
step into these positions will be
focused on those explanations of how to
actually solve some of the pressing
issues of our time now
okay after a hundred and three of these
over the last three years this you know
like you said includes representatives
cofounders of big companies union
leaders
all these different people you know the
three years that you've done here what
have you seen of all these trials that
are happening we were talking about them
as kind of like permutations seeing
which ones are going to be successful is
that kind of how you've also been seeing
it as different permutations occurring
and measuring them success yes and no I
mean I think a big part of I mean well
yes yes and more I guess would be the
more accurate one there yeah I think
it's it's really important to just see
what happens when you give people money
in the current context in you know in
the u.s. right now in the other some in
Canada there's some all over the place
you know I think there's gonna be some
universals there and some that are very
specific to that place in that time so
yeah I think these experiments are
experiments they're also really good
exposure the one there's one that just
started in Stockton California yeah and
that is both an experiment to see what
happens but also they're very focused on
collecting stories from those people you
know how did it change your life to get
there getting and believe $500 a month
the people selected there and you know I
think those those stories can really
make this make sense to a lot of people
where they say okay yeah now I see that
you know you you're kind of making ends
meet before but now with the sector of
500 bucks a month you don't have to
think about what you're gonna give up
when your kids need school supplies or
like they're they're you know ripping
their clothes and you need like a new
set of clothes and that's a burden for a
lot of people you know for some people
they they don't just have a little bit
of extra money lying around
you know something breaks and you do fix
it you get a new one or or do you just
not have that thing anymore and what if
that thing's really important what if
that's your car so does a percentage is
crazy I think it was something like 50%
of people in the United States can't
afford a $500 bill yeah yeah and I feel
like movements like these need facts
like that I hear that one all the time
and I've say it all the time
because it's one of these things where
it kind of hits you like oh like that's
just a problem that needs solving
and sure things like healthcare
education jobs programs there's lots of
stuff that we can do to kind of bank
shot that policy or that that problem
but we can also just give people money
and what a I'd say the if you're gonna
take one key finding from the basic
income research we do have already it's
that the the issues around poverty are a
lack of money it's not a lack of
character it's not sometimes it can be a
lack of services as well but to make
people to get people out of poverty you
give them money and then they're not in
poverty anymore there are other routes
out there's you know maybe you get a
great education and you get the skills
you need to get a good job and sure that
can absolutely happen of course having a
little Economic Security alongside that
certainly makes it easier to survive
while you're getting that education or
whatever that path is those happen there
are these rags to riches stories and
they're beautiful and wonderful and I
think we'd see more of them if we had a
basic income but also there are people
suffering who they don't need a rags to
riches story they don't need this like
brilliant idea where they bust out of
their their poor town where like
everyone's struggling they could also we
could also just take care of those
people and figure out the details after
that
yeah the 50 percent potentially at the
population that's so stiff so at the
edge just barely keeping their heads
afloat including projects like ours and
many others in San Francisco that are
trying to be artists or entrepreneurs
around the world just giving them that
little bit of breathing room so it's not
always a trade-off between like food and
supplies for the project or whatever it
may be like that now yes you're you're
super you're super on point like it just
it just seems like the money takes
people out of poverty at the same time
as meaning or purpose does as well a lot
of times so it's kind of like has to
come a little bit with a meaning or a
purpose something to you know to wake up
every morning and be passionate about
doing but also to have your head above
above the water with your ability to to
stay afloat
well you walk
through like out when we when I was
researching what you guys were we're
highlighting this is everything from
like the 70s in the United States I
think it was like Denver in Seattle in
Indiana or some of the places when were
piloting some of the basic income
projects all the way to you know Canada
and now it's America Latin America it's
all over the place so like yeah walk us
through maybe a little bit of like a
history sure yeah so in the seventies
the basic income movements it wasn't
this like fledgling thing that most
people hadn't heard about in Nixon's
re-election campaign both him and his
opponent had basic income plans as part
of their platform and it felt like basic
income was going to happen in some form
either a sort of more there's a
conservative end of it where you would
cut or get rid of a lot of social
programs and just give people cash then
there is the more liberal side where it
would be more like more generous basic
income properly plus those programs but
that was the debate it wasn't basic
income or not basic income it was what
kind of basic income and but there were
there were concerns came up some
objections from from various sides and
so after Nixon got reelected we had some
basic income trials in the US to sort of
see what happens get some evidence
around this and you know those places
you mentioned and also yeah the town of
Delfin and Canada and and you see a lot
of those effects so a lot of the
research that eventually came out of
that was people were better educated
they didn't quit their jobs by and large
the only places where you saw the only
groups that stayed out of the work force
a bit longer or new moms stayed it was
taking care of their kids a little bit
longer and students specifically high
school students you also saw things like
emergency room visits went down both for
physical and mental issues domestic
violence rates went down crime rates
went down so it's you start to see all
these things as symptoms of poverty that
we're just addressed by taking care of
the poverty part of it you know again
not the only thing you need to do to
have a thriving healthy society but a
big
big part of it one other finding that
was eventually turned out to be a
statistical error but it was initially
thought that in places that had a basic
income the divorce rate when skyrocketed
and and that was enough to kill the
program to me if the divorce rate was
going up that probably means that there
are a lot of people in relationships
that where they're just there for the
financial security and not for the
actual relationship and maybe it's okay
that maybe it's a good thing that those
are moving on same thing if people are
quitting their jobs because they're
getting like a poverty level of you know
a thousand dollars a month would be
roughly poverty level for for everyone
if people are quitting their jobs
because they're getting $1,000 a month
that probably means they're in a job
that was like pretty unhealthy for them
in some level anyway the divorce rate
finding turned out to not be accurate it
was some statistical error but that was
enough to kind of kill the momentum and
you know American politics moved on to
other things
and then in the 2000s we start to see
this revival and some of it's driven by
automation that there are these
increasing concerns that you know the
whole robots are coming for our jobs
thing there's a lot to unpack there and
I think in some industries some sectors
yeah the robots are coming and then some
they're already here and that's gonna be
something we have to address in a basic
income I think could be part of that
some people just see it as an
anti-poverty measure that you know we
have all these people half the
population can't afford an unexpected
expense of $400 and that's a crisis that
means we are those people are suffering
some of those people are going to have
an expensive four hundred dollars and
who knows what happens after that some
of those people could be the next
Einstein or Bill Gates or you know throw
you know Jim Henson whoever you want to
throw in there but you know they're
there working at Walmart or they're
working or they're not working they're
just doing what they can to make it
through the next day the next week and
they don't have time - one of the tools
to contemplate the cosmos yeah the
cosmos you know and then they have to
you know they have to put food on the
table the next day so you know are they
gonna bust out and start their tech
company maybe but you know they'd have a
lot better sound if they had a
little bit of income security so that
the movement is rising again especially
among young people I feel like they see
it as a big part of what we need in the
economy growing forward and so there's
there's the automation part of it
there's also globalization you know now
you're competing with your labour for
people not just people in your town or
your city or your state but the entire
world and there's also the rise of
contract work so there's a ton of people
who have jobs that were there contract
workers because their employers don't
want to pay benefits or they've kind of
figured well we could just have a ten
hour a week contract worker or a for six
months a year contract worker instead of
having someone where we employ them and
then we have to give them benefits we
have to find the more stuff to do and we
could just kind of turn the volume knob
up and down in terms of how much labor
were employing at any given time very
convenient for an employer we happen to
not have a benefit system that takes
care of those people when those those
employers don't need them anymore so you
throw all those factors together and you
realize that our safety net has not been
updated basically since LBJ you know
that's not strictly true but that was
the last major revamp we've had and you
start to think well maybe we should just
take care of people so that employers
aren't you know they don't have this
burden of you know having to bribe
health care and retirement benefits that
made a ton of sense you know in the
post-world War two ERA where you are
gonna stick with your employer for a
long time maybe probably your whole
career and if you lost your job you
could probably find another one in six
months I should caveat that with we're
mostly talking about white men when we
talk about that women were largely out
of the workforce people of color you
know were you know discriminated against
in any number of ways but for the people
the economy was designed for for our
benefits were designed for they worked
well enough and they haven't been
updated as frequently or as thoughtfully
as we need to to actually take care of
people and respond to the economy as it
is today and to account for the changes
that we can't really anticipate yeah
that's a very very beautiful summary
because you're explaining this all the
way from the 70s and I'm thinking
like okay this last 50 year period of
time and Eric Weinstein is you know
really really trying to teach this on an
economic level to more people but you
just see GDP just going up and up and up
a median male income is just flat yeah
and so you're like where are all of
these profits going that the cut that
the United States is now starting to
flourish so much well a lot of its just
going into the hands of the shareholders
of the companies that are making all the
for all of the money meanwhile the
people the middle class poor people are
the ones that are buying the goods and
using the products that are that are
being created so then that in in in you
know there's so many ways to explain how
to potentially make this new code
deployment we were talking about you
know a basic income
what about basic assets maybe some of
the people that are working at these
companies are some of the people that
are buying the products of services
deserve a tiny little bit of the
shareholder value and that way they can
have some sort of an asset we're talking
about a carbon the carbon dividend
yes paid out we're talking about you
know Alaska has their oil dividend that
they've already been paying out yeah
about two hundred bucks a month is what
I saw is like an average yeah so it's
like one two three K a year so yeah I
kind of okay oh yeah something around
that and then there's there's this other
thing the sovereign fund that you were
explained to me earlier as well so now
let's talk about all these different
deployments there's a negative income
tax and accounts for teach us about yeah
so plenty of the unpack there so there's
the basic income idea of everyone gets
let's say $1,000 a month just for being
a person and that's kind of like what a
lot of basic income advocates would
think of as sort of the pure version
then you have something like a negative
income we could explain how to pay for
that too like so idea like Andrew said
yeah two trillion a year we can down
there's like 500 billion of that is
already in what's paid out in welfare
than the eight hundred billion or so at
the value-added tax yeah where coal
companies pay a tax for part of the
production process of creating a good
ray hopefully they don't increase their
rates of there yeah it's so much to
cancel that out yeah
and yes yeah so sure so we could do a
little dive there yeah and honestly how
you pay for the basic income is
obviously one of the major defining
factors and what the policy actually is
and you'll get different answers based
on on who you ask
the idea I am most excited by right now
is the idea of a carbon tax carbon
dividend and that won't be a full basic
income you could get up to like in the
low ish hundreds per person with an
aggressive carbon tax but would really I
mean this is already a big topic in my
head and so corporations pay so yeah the
way we're polluting the environment sure
I mean that that's you know the way you
might do it is you put a fee on carbon
extraction so you're digging oil out of
the ground you're mining coal you pay a
certain amounts to do that and maybe
that mining company that drilling
company then they might pass that fee
along and it might end up you know
having our electricity go up and calm
right yeah but if you take the that
money so in in France they proposed
something like that and there were
protests in the street because you know
as much as people want to fight climate
change they also want to make ends meet
they don't want their gas prices to go
up if you take that those funds that
revenue from those oil companies and you
just distribute them you just say
everyone gets this this amount of a
dividend then that goes from a
regressive tax to a progressive tax and
all of a sudden you're fighting poverty
and climate change at the same time and
you haven't spent any money other than
the administrative costs of just
collecting that money and distributing
it we have the graphic for the citizens
climate Lobby that you shared with us
yeah that we can also show the viewers
yeah it's all good we get thro thro the
it so they own and there we'll get to
that one later for sure yeah
Bobby we'll get to the UVI one yeah yeah
yeah
yeah yeah so this is proposed by the
citizens climate Lobby yeah and this is
legislation in the US Congress right now
right now bipartisan climate solution
energy innovation and carbon dividend
Act
this is 763 bill 763 drive down
America's carbon pollution and bring
climate change under control okay and
then Ron let's bring us down scroll us
down through this
okay so charge a fee on fossil fuels at
the source returned a hundred percent of
net revenue to households as a dividend
this is what you were just explaining
yeah yeah okay and then how do you the
how do the fossil fuel companies not
pass along the extra fee to the
electrical companies then they might
they might and so and they probably will
you know at some point the the market
will determine you know how if it's the
whole thing or part of it but this has
been studied and so yeah let's say gas
prices go up construction costs go up
you know things that have to be
transported a long distance those prices
go up this has been studied and what's
been found is that things get better if
you are you know in the bottom like 80
at least percent pop of the population
basically if you are poor lower class
middle class maybe even upper middle
class you're either the same or better
it's all we're gonna get 200 bucks maybe
a month in in a carbon dividend and then
your electricity will only go up 50
bucks a month something like so that's
the general way right you're better off
yeah and if you're not better off you're
probably rich in which I'm okay with
then you're not like it's not like
you're way worse off if you're rich
you're just like a tiny bit it's like a
rounding error for the richest among us
and again you're fighting climate change
and poverty I I try to disseminate this
policy as much as I possibly can because
I think it's it could be just something
that it's it's just kind of a win all
around like I really don't see any
issues with it some people say we should
have a carbon tax but we should use the
money differently and you know I'm Pro
carbon tax however you can get it
through but I think this is a good way
to get it through and you're addressing
other problems and you see the green new
deal as kind of this other approach of
this kind of like big public tying
together
economic growth with environmental
protection and and I think that's a
great idea to you know have this massive
public works program where you know
we're installing solar we're making our
trains more efficient we're making our
home
more efficient you know all you can go
down the list but I think that's that's
maybe half the equation the other half
you can just put this pressure on the
market you say polluting costs more and
those costs gets just distributed to
balance that out and it's it's elegant
it's simple and there it says bipartisan
climate solution because a lot of
Republicans say well yeah maybe climate
change is an issue but they don't want
to do all these big programs but this is
this is basically revenue neutral and
it's it's relying on the market to just
kind of hash out you know what happens
when we when we make energy more
expensive to make it more reflects you
know with the the actual costs having on
all of our lives interesting now I mean
this this seems so right like that that
we could figure out how to pass along a
dividend that is that a lot of the
shareholders at the major companies that
are also polluting the environment for
free right now that they can have that
carbon tax
hopefully the electrical the electricity
costs don't get increased an equal
amounts are just voids the same thing
with like the data dividend that Gavin
Newsom is putting together like can we
potentially make it that the tech
companies that are profiting in the
hundreds of billions of dollars can we
somehow make it so that that the that
the US we get out a little bit as a
dividend from us providing them with our
data and that as long as the cost to use
their services don't increase in the
same amount that we get it dividend
that's kind of just like this is a big
reoccurring thing that's coming that's
coming up how do we ensure that like for
me it's a lot of it is about a period of
spiritual growth the job creation here
is really important as well I'm the
amount of jobs that get created through
things like the the new technological
movements but a lot of it's about the
spiritual development like if people
that are at the tops of these
hierarchies that are making some of the
most amounts of money if there we go if
we help us get through a process of
spiritual development and just then just
really tying us together with all that
is at a deeper level with
how we are so interconnected that then
it it almost becomes more of we're not
just gonna do some top-down Force
regulation but it's more like I want to
be a part of the Giving Pledge I want to
be a part of these transitions that we
need to make sure that the grandchildren
have a planet to play on and to be
creatively flourish and that they don't
have issues with when they're birthed
into the world do you kinda feel me on
that like spiritual development and
connection side of things - I do I guess
I mean yeah I I think that's the ideal
right that this isn't something where we
have to like forcibly take your your
resources your assets then it's more of
like we're all in this together if you
know that it should be that what's
what's good for everyone is good for
everyone and that we just both feel that
even if it means you can't afford as
many yachts as you would like that you
you recognize that this is for the
collective and that is then and that is
just good and that you feel that if
you're this you know rich Oleg arc or a
politician who controls a lot of things
that that even if yeah but that there
might be some nominal personal
sacrifices or maybe not even nominal
that go toward a betterment of the whole
yes the other side of that I would say
is that I don't necessarily want to wait
for the spiritual awakening of me
neither they come hand in hand mm-hmm
helping with the spiritual awakening at
st. deals making moves making actual
movement that is so needed to eradicate
suffering yeah other than enabling the
purchase of the fifth see yeah but you
get way more meaning in life from the
from helping pass along absolutely yeah
and I'll say that I think it can
actually happen in the other direction
that if you are in a society where
people are just taken care of and you
take that as normal that you know we if
that starts to go away then you'll feel
that loss and so it's not just that we
have to get people on board with this
big holistic vision
of the world and then make it happen if
you could just kind of sneak it in there
sometimes then people say oh yeah this
is good that this feels right and the
growth can happen that way too
yeah okay so then you know there seems
to be like this is this was one of them
the carbon dividend data dividend we
unpacked those there's you know the
basic income how we pay for that you
know a negative income tax like people
that are just not making yeah we can
explain that one yeah cash transfers
yeah yeah so the great appeal of the
negative income tax is that he basically
pays for itself the idea is that so
let's say you're making a million
dollars a year you have an income tax on
that and that you know the government
takes a chunk of that and you know they
take a little bit less if you're making
500k 100k on down and then at a certain
point instead of you giving the
government money the government gives
you money if they were making like ten
thousand a year the government may give
you supplemental income of ten thousand
a year from that pool that they withdraw
right yeah and so it's um and so as you
earn more then you get less from the
government and that once you cross it at
a certain point you're you're out the
the break-even point employee and and
then above that you're paying into the
system and this is where would the
incentive come to actually get to that
break-even point of twenty thousand like
you know like so you if there's
essentially a tax on all income one way
or another whether you're taking in less
or earning less the more you earn the
you know the less you get from the
government I mean you know that I assume
the same place it comes from now where
let's say if if we have a negative
income tax yeah let's use your example
of if you're making 10k you get an
additional 10k ten thousand and if once
you're up to thirty thousand dollars
then you're only printing an extra
$5,000 okay so now you're making thirty
five thousand of dollars a year it's
better than twenty thousand and maybe
the financial incentives are not as
strong and maybe you you would adjust
the slope of the and the you know
break-even point to find a place where
the incentives to make money are where
we think they should be and I don't
exactly know where that would be
but but people want to make more money
now people making $100,000 a year who
are getting taxed quite heavily and will
get taxed more if they go beyond that
they still want to make more money most
of them and so yeah I don't I'm not
currently worried about the incentive
issue I think we're not talking about
levels of basic income right now that
we're it's like if you if we're talking
about like everyone gets $40,000 a year
unconditionally okay yeah then people
might say like yeah I'm gonna quit my
job because I can just live on that and
I'm fine with forty thousand dollars a
year and twelve thousand dollars a year
some people are just gonna coast most
people want a bit more than that
and whether that's a negative income tax
or or dividend interesting yeah I'm I
also tend to tend to agree that there's
like a strong driver for people to find
meaning or purpose in the world and that
that will then be the incentive for them
to go and make things and build things
yeah at the same time we do see quite a
lot of of hierarchical dynamics that are
so slowly but surely over the last 50
years
slightly inhibiting people from from
achieving self-actualization the
resource flows aren't quite there the
the the we were just you were just
making it really clear that like people
at some point are just not as better off
as their parents yeah or when they're
growing up and so a lot of these prompts
can't just be pushed off into like
laziness but actually like like well how
much easier is the climb up in the past
than it was now is another way to
potentially raise that and think about
it how many more people are there on the
planet now how much etcetera these these
questions and then cash transfers and
the sovereign fund we can yeah she's
having a well fund so Alaska's been
doing this for over 30 years almost 40
actually and what they do it's a
convenient example is they have a whole
lot of oil up in Alaska and that's
government lands the the government
gives oil companies the rights to drill
on that land
and they in that cost money to the oil
companies and so barrel companies pay
the state of Alaska Alaska puts that in
the fund invests it over a number of
years and then each year they provide a
dividend to everyone who lives in Alaska
and it's been historically about one to
three thousand dollars per year and it's
incredibly popular because people like
getting money and there are a lot of I
interviewed on the podcast Bill will a
cow ski who is a representative up there
and it's a state senator and and he
talked about how you've got these very
remote villages in Alaska you think you
know what our remote town looks like
well you know imagine if like you you
have to take a plane just to get to your
town about a hundred people yeah and you
know like getting a jug of milk will
have to you know it requires the same
thing yeah an extra like two thousand
dollars per year and that's per person
so if you have a family of four that's
eight thousand dollars a year for a
family that makes a huge difference so
that's the the sovereign wealth fund
idea is you have this fund where it's
not directly distributed to everyone
it's not just money and money out it's
money in its invested and then
distributed as a dividend and not
necessarily a hundred percent of it goes
toward a dividend it could go to or
other community social projects but
that's that's the basic concept and it
doesn't have to be your your oil
reserves it could be a carbon tax it
could be a financial transaction tax it
could be a date of dividend it could be
a land value tax this is an idea that is
very prominent in the basic income space
that's zoltan's idea so Tami chiffons
oh yeah I'm actually not super up on on
what he's proposed but it's often
associated with Henry George it was a
thinker of a previous time and and yeah
he's often kind of thought of as the the
biggest were like that are the original
proponent of the plan value tax and
that's the idea that you know you you
own a plot of lands and if you have a
mansion on that land or if it's just you
know nothing you get you get taxed on
the value of the land so in San
Francisco
that's gonna be kind of high and you
know if you go you know 100 miles south
of here
you might just be kind of in a random
desert in California
that same area of land is not gonna cost
you the same amount because if you just
think about like an undeveloped lot
that's gonna cost like a million dollars
in San Francisco where it's gonna cost
like ten thousand dollars in another
part of the state of the country and so
so that's kind of how to think about a
land value tax and that's you know you
could think of that as a collective
asset who owns the land well you know a
lot of mostly wealthy people or people
who were fortunate enough to to buy in
in cheaper times but who should own the
land like well it may not make sense to
try to distribute lands in some kind of
even way where everyone gets the same
amount or something like that or I don't
know but we could kind of acknowledge
that we have this very unequal
distribution of lands based on nothing
that really comes from any kind of moral
compass it's just who has money and who
is in the right place in the right time
and maybe that they should pay into this
collective system and so anyway you've
put all these funds together you have
your your sovereign wealth fund you can
invest it you could just invest it
essentially in the US economy through
index funds and bombs whatever else and
and that could grow over time and we
could collectively get a dividend from
all these these assets that it's feels
on some sense we should be collectively
owned but doesn't logistically make
sense to actually collectively own them
so and then you distribute it out
interesting okay so so collecting from
all the different assets from all the
different sort of major players that
we're all contributing to the wealth
being grown in those orgs
but then there's not a sort of sovereign
fund that can then collectively
distribute that wealth that we're all
putting towards the growth of these
assets so no that kind of you know
around we can maybe we can show that out
second image that we didn't that we
haven't gotten to yet that when they
first pulled up here what I was telling
you a little bit you know before
beforehand that I
think you know we can maybe touch on on
now is you know when you look at when I
look at something like this
I definitely think of how the read the
redistribution is at some in some way it
just it's a little bit like it makes
sometimes it makes people feel a little
uneasy to like seeing if they are fine
if people find themselves in this read
along the top left they have maybe like
20 of these marbles stacked right so
you're losing this many marbles so
you're losing maybe let's say seven or
so of your marbles and then you're
redistributing those seven marbles to
the poor socio-economic statuses now
versus another way that I've kind of
been trying to explain it like this is
looks like a zero-sum game where the
readout yeah whose marbles they
increased one in the lower SES versus
like the idea of the the red continuing
to increase by five or seven marbles but
meanwhile the lower SES also increases
by five or seven or eight or 10 even
marbles which makes it so that they go
way out of poverty level meanwhile the
red continues to increase as well which
makes it so that it's a it's a positive
sum game as well as the wealthy realms
of people currently don't get don't
become all hesitated and like I don't
want to lose money because then they're
not they're actually continuing to gain
so there's ways to make these dividends
and distributions happen in a way that
it constantly increases the the some
yeah I think that's a good point
and you know you got a lot of familiar
questions once you're in the basic
income movement for long enough and one
of them is is this essentially taking
money from the rich and giving it to the
poor and you know and certainly a
negative income tax is exactly that and
a lot of schemes have have that basic
result and in terms of a what
distribution looks like I'm okay with
this being step one what happens after
step one well these folks now have more
money so you know if you're a business
owner you know those are people who now
have expendable income that they didn't
have and they're gonna spend money a lot
faster than the red column and so
the economy will be stimulated you know
to to an incredible degree also there
will be less social spending on things
like health care our you know a lot of
poverty fighting measures a lot of you
know you know social ills like crime
issues those have all been shown to
decrease under basic income similar
argument to universal health care or
it's like we could have this kind of
Genki system where if you you can kind
of pay in more and get more but if we
just had a single-payer the United
States government it's just a more
efficient system and so it's good for
everyone
so you could think of this as step one
where it's like okay through the
taxation system through however we do it
yeah the the richer chunks take a little
we take a little bit more out of your
pie and everyone gets everyone gets
their slice of pie but the long-term
results of that are yeah you live in a
more prosperous society you live in a
happier cleaner society you live in a
healthier society you live in a society
where you have more potential customers
to your business you have more people
with expendable income you have people
getting a check and you know what day
they're getting the check on it and you
can have your car sale or whatever to to
try to bring that added economic
activity to you so I think yeah even if
we are redistributing as step 1 steps 2
through 10 are all about growth for
everyone yeah yeah yeah you you also
brought up something super interesting
there which is just all the decrease
costs that civilization has it gets to
reap the benefits of when people are not
just joking trying to get above the line
with water level is because then they're
you know these all of the expenditures
that for health care decrease these are
the crime rates decrease these are very
interesting things that I think need to
be you know studied more and drilled in
more that eradicating poverty is saving
people money a lot of money is saving
countries lots of money now now to play
on the on the sovereign fund as well as
I want to explain what your thoughts are
asking what your thoughts are here along
the lines of like a sovereign fund would
take all of that we're contributing to
all of these assets but only the
shareholders are reaping the benefits
so then then redistributing that into a
fund that we can then reap that we can
then get a dividend from is like a
sovereign front style now a universal
basic asset argument this is kind of
what Douglas rushkoff framed and I
thought was very fascinating is that you
know why not just all the people that
are contributing to the the growth of
these assets why not just give really
small percentages of the assets to the
people that are contributing so instead
of just getting a dividend from the data
why not actually have me own that asset
that I'm already contributing and then
getting paid from that that way it's
like a non and ownership level what are
your thoughts on that asset ownership
yeah no I like the concept a lot and you
know rush cops sort of thought about
this a bit more than I have but yeah and
I feel like there there's really
something there to just use give
everyone that ownership stake and that's
sort of getting into the sovereign
wealth fund idea and I you know it's
sort of think about the logistics of it
where you know maybe a just a collective
wealth fund would be the easier way to
do it so you don't have to like own your
stake of the data dividend and your
stake of the financial transaction tax
in your state of the carbon tax I don't
know if that's what he's proposing
specifically but but you know I like the
idea I'm certainly a fan of the interval
universal basic assets concepts where
where we have you know like Wikipedia I
think is kind of a good stock example
where it's this is basically a
collective resource you know they they
fundraise and whatnot but but they're
not for profit and you can imagine a
world where we have like shared vehicles
that are just kind of there for for
usage like all this stuff that like some
of it we have like public libraries and
some of it you could imagine for our
modern world I think that's all great I
don't see any conflict between having
that and having something like an API it
seems like now like I want to ask you
about this you know we're moving into
the age of exponential technology and
automation artificial intelligence and
robotics and you know something that was
interesting that Andra K just mentioned
on our episode yesterday a manager and
director of Silicon Valley robotics is
that we
need identifiers on the robots so as we
have a license plate on a car on a plane
or on a boat all these different great
there's license placers licensing that
if we have these identifiers zhan robots
that have licenses it makes it easier
for us to identify potential malevolent
actors and it makes it easier for us to
identify which ones are which licenses
are paying taxes right which robots are
paying taxes for the amount of work
they're doing that kind of stuff and
then it makes it easier to potentially
have that be an asset that's shared
amongst people and get dividends
potentially from it now with your
thoughts on the exponential technologies
that are that are occurring as well as a
lot of the wealth and equality that is
that is occurring what are your thoughts
around like skills that young people
need to develop in order to stay
relevant in in the exponential
technology age and obviously we've
talked about all the different styles of
trying to help with the wealth
inequality gap with all the dividends
and stuff we've talked about but give us
your thoughts on that exponential
technology agents skills when you
develop it yourself yeah I mean it's
obviously a big topic right now and I
mean this isn't gonna be new to anyone
but you know everyone's learning to code
now and and what's coding it's it's your
ability to talk to a computer to get a
computer to do what you want to do and
you know the languages that in the
frameworks people are learning right now
who knows if they're even gonna be a
thing in ten years but at least kind of
knowing where something now is gonna be
helpful down the road and you know we
could be seeing a world where if you
want to be a doctor or an engineer or
receptionist or whatever you have to
have some coding skills
it wouldn't be shocking to me if that's
the world were headed toward where
that's just you know not quite as basic
as reading but it's getting there yeah
in terms of other skills that you need I
mean one one kind of breakdown that you
you hear a lot when people talk about
automation taking jobs is if something
is non-routine then that's humans are
better at that if it's anything routine
whether it's mint
or physical you can build a robot to do
that whether it's software hardware some
comma ho and if it's a if it's more of a
cognitive task so not routine cognitive
tasks do we have enough non routine
cognitive tasks to go around I'm not
sure
are we really headed toward an economy
where that's what we'll need humans for
and not a whole lot else I'm also not
sure but and how do you teach all that
I'm also not sure but I think those at
least are the questions that our
education system needs to be grappling
with and I know that you know a lot of
Education is around preparing you for
the economy and that makes sense when
you when you graduate high school or
college you should be ready for some
kind of job all that said I really don't
want to throw out the humanities you
know we you know we read your classic
literature read your not classic
literature know your history all that
stuff even if it it's not going to help
you like get a job like it helps you be
a person and that's you know a lot of
what education was thought to be for you
know in the earlier days when you were
just kind of guaranteed did I move into
whatever sort of system you were born
into I think that might be an artifact
of a previous system but it's a valuable
one and one that we shouldn't lose track
of when we talk about you know with what
the kids need to learn right now yeah
like your like your continued emphasis
on understanding how to engage and
interact with with code and with
computing as well as creativity super
super important non routine tasks things
that lie outside the crosshairs of
software there's a very very important
okay now you know a couple couple
thoughts on on the way out you know
you're gonna be continuing to do
episodes on the basic income podcast
that's you know where what else are you
thinking about in the future of your
work and
yeah yeah well I mean I don't know if
I'll be doing work around this
presidential election but this is a big
moment where we're thinking about big
ideas and kind of medium-sized ideas
about what direction should we be going
in right now this is kind of like a big
countrywide public forum where we're
talking about this stuff so I'll be
engaged on that on some level I'm also
so this is actually news as of a couple
days ago I've just been appointed to the
Berkeley cannabis commission so I'm part
of now an advisory board that talks to
the the City Council and makes
recommendations so that'll be and that's
that's previous to UVI that was sort of
another galvanizing issue legalization
totally has been a big issue for me
Congrats that's a really cool position
yeah thank you see yeah that's exciting
and a nice way to kind of stay involved
in local government after my you run for
office you kind of learn all these like
levers and different things that go on
and in local politics and how things
actually happen in government and so
it's nice to have found a little spot to
continue to be involved I also write
about baseball so if you're a baseball
fan you can you can find me out there
and yeah yeah it's sort of always been
like a childhood thing that suddenly
became a job it's a fun sport yeah yeah
yeah I enjoy it and you played - no no
not Little League yeah yeah yeah yeah
you know still the occasional Dreamworks
like suddenly I'm on the Mets but yeah
in terms of what I do going forward
I feel like climate change in basic
income are like the things I think we
need to be thinking really hard about
right now and I you know hope to be part
of those conversations going forward
both you know in the political realm and
just wherever we can we can nudge things
forward I think if we get those things
right you know that's not everything but
that's that's a big chunk that'll be a
load off my mind and
and I think a load off a lot of other
people's make it easier for people to
have families and kids and continue yeah
on the planet for sure for sure hitting
those tackling those issues I have a lot
of faith in Millennials and Gen Z mm-hmm
all right let's ask a couple quick
questions on the way out
yes question do you believe we're alone
in the cosmos mm-hmm
probably not I mean just uh you know
statistically it's big cosmos um you
know given the speed of light and how
far away things are nothing kind of
blows my mind just didn't like the scale
of space like the size of stars like
even like the size of Jupiter or how
Jupiter has a storm that's been going
for a hundred years it's bigger than
planet Earth so I don't know if we're
ever gonna make contact or if we have
already or who knows but but yeah it's
probably some stuff out there probably
some of it's a lot smarter than us and
you has intelligence that we can't even
like wrap our minds around and yeah who
knows where but it's probably somewhere
this is simulation so we must ask you
are we in a simulation I don't know I
mean that I guess if we are in a
simulation then then what's what's being
simulated and who's doing the simulating
I do think there's one idea I've thought
a lot about is we are we are these
machines that were you know whatever you
want to call us that perceive we have
these tools like eyes and ears and touch
that that perceive energy on some level
and then through that we have human
experience and what what is the leap
between our input of you know like light
waves and sound waves and you know the
the electronic fields and whatever that
I can feel to to actually just like
having this lived experience where I'm
walking down the street and seeing stuff
and so you know and sympathetic for the
idea that we are all on some level
simulating our own lives are we in a
collective simulation I don't know I
don't know what would make it so that I
mean this is kind of like the decart
thing or it's like I don't know if I can
even is tricking me I don't know like
what's going on but I know that I've got
mental activity so I am a thing that
exists I think therefore I am
that's you know and I don't know how how
you get much further than that in terms
of defining reality and if I you know
what happens if it turns out that we are
in a simulation what's what's the real
stuff like you know am i a computer chip
am I a snail and my thing that looks
like me but yeah I don't know so yeah I
guess I have more questions than answers
there and I don't know what the envelope
yeah love it love it was a lot of good
stuff
very important to unpack that and to
continue to probe at the the simulation
with our scientific hypotheses try and
figure it out
last question oh and what do you believe
is the most beautiful thing in the world
ooh yikes I think just looking up at the
sky at night and seeing the Stars and
just knowing that that is a 100%
universal experience that every human
who has ever lived everyone who lives is
living right now has has done that and
has seen those same stars and and and
just that that we've all got this like
shared shared perspective on some level
that you know whoever you are whatever
you believe however you treat people you
know we've we've all done that and we've
all maybe appreciated the beauty of that
and that beauty itself is this weird
human experience that you know maybe
maybe other animals other life-forms
experience it as well but all you can
say for sure is that humans experience
beauty and I'm not even sure what it's
for or why we have that experience but
everyone does and that you can have
these experiences where you look at a
sunset or it's like everyone thinks this
is beautiful right and like why like and
then it doesn't matter why but it's they
just have that knowledge that we have
this this level of shared experience
that for some reason we just find it
meaningful and beautiful and powerful
and and I don't even really need to know
why that is
oh man those those universal beauties
that's that's a really good one yeah
yeah star sunsets yes yes oh and thank
you so much for coming onto the show
Thank You Alice great yeah yeah we love
your work very much we find it to be
extremely important to have more of
these conversations around the world so
huge thank you for the basic income
podcast and all your working in
measuring all these experiments that are
happening and teaching about them a huge
thank you to everyone that tuned in we
greatly appreciate you we'd love to hear
your thoughts in the comments below let
us know what you were thinking what your
thoughts are about basically income go
and share the messages around with other
people about the ways that we can
structure society to better maximize
people's potential huge shout out to Ron
Vargas thank you very much for producing
and directing we love you very much also
go and support the artists and
entrepreneurs that you believe in right
all of one's links are below go and
check out his links don't check out the
podcast subscribe there support them if
you believe in them support simulation
our links are below if you believed in
us and go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world how
can we write this code to maximize our
potential we love you so much and we'll
see you soon thanks everyone peace
[Music]
[Music]